the movie is about these mercenaries who
are in China to steal gunpowder we get
captured by the fictitious army called
the nameless order and their job is to
defend the wall against this wave of a
monster attacks that happen every 60
years we stumble onto the Great Wall
kind of on the eve of one of these so
basically we end up fighting alongside
this Chinese army to try to ascend the
wall from monsters so it's a giant
monster movie yo voy allá de las ting
Mesa Kenyan the trans warranty with
poverty tada chocolate an example that
will be an untruth civic leaders in
France automobile machine grocery co thi
autonomy free delivery fees and anodic
and ocean your engine control under
Tonto the to work interaction is young
as you are here to worldly issues on
from Waimea war when you ego talk here
again just leave by Johnny you will see
you in a glacial the Aussie enjoy this
is well controlled hood it's very
exciting to see our cinematographers
work Chang Mo's were actors like ching
ching he was sort of new like me and
andy lau who's been around like Matt
Damon but at the end of the day it's
really about entertainment having a good
time
the first battle I think it's just nuts
i mean it's when we see their army in
all their glory kind of for the first
time they fight like spectacularly well
so that sequence the way it's
choreographed the camera moves the scope
the scale the wall kind of comes alive
almost like it was built by Leonardo da
Vinci like you know catapult come out
and things right exactly it's just a
really kind of epic thing she on you
should you should be ready for the
dental or do this bigger folders in for
doing that I'm extra logical order at
our gender should be on your feet on
topic we know in ritardo you another
question from universal we are just me
vagina don't rely on some social issue
young attorney in question they also
tell me the condo good team atrocity
Sumerian texts one question just leavin
extrano thing back in your journey not
generally using horses eating on your
iron man that's a while we have Changi
mo who is probably the most visually
stunning director alive and this insane
story that is about a fortified Great
Wall of China battling monsters and so
we want that to be as big as it can
possibly
we wanted to feel as big as it felt
making the money and i think that the
imax screen is obviously the only way to
achieve that donna Zeus is what about
their you gonna be like a magazine black
socks are you how you handle amigo son
Jesus yo boy or do the two American
people don't feel hopeless you know it's
just overwhelming in the right way and
this is exactly the type of movie that
you would want to see is take a format
as possible because of the level of
detail that's the version I want to see
it into this the only version i will let
my friends get it i wonder if it can be
seen on anything but than I men